he is one of the 122 names on the list
for enshrinement in the pro football
hall of fame and he deserves it uh he is
part of thursday night football's
pregame and halftime and post-game
coverage um tonight from houston where
the carolina panthers try to go to three
and oh he's our friend steve smith back
here on the show how are you doing steve
what's up rich how are you doing i'm
doing better for talking to you
i'm doing better for you sweet talking
to me already you know what steve that's
just the way i roll but that's the way i
feel about you too i'll say that to you
off the air as well as you know um
how's your family everybody good
man everybody's doing great okay
everybody's doing great okay
of course it is my pleasure let's get
into uh tonight's game what do you think
is going on in the texans locker room
where it's obvious that there's not a
chance on this green earth that any
scenario could unfold
where desean watson will either be asked
to play and put them on the spot
or
or desean watson will
essentially say i'll play i i just gotta
i i'm seeing my teammates do x y and z
what do you think's going on there
that's very interesting i don't really
know you know this is really unfortunate
territories for for a lot of us know to
have
uh everything that's going on
with the sean watson with the houston
texans
um this is like i said uncharted
territories nobody really knows what's
going on we're not really hearing a lot
of stuff
so i think you know every
your guess is probably good as mine just
because you
what do you do do you let them play do
you not let them play you know it's it's
uh
it's just messy to be honest
right and i'm just wondering again if
players are just going to be
you know um if they've already put it in
a box and haven't they just know it's
not possible and just going to forget
about it and and so far i mean the first
two weeks they they they've looked much
better than anybody could have expected
or thought they're going to start their
rookie guy tonight steve you know
they have looked much better um you know
when you get the jags that that always
helps you right
right that's you know that's that that
unfortunately right now between the jags
and what the lions actually that's that
should get right games right there um
so
i'm not
you know i think tyrod's done a good job
and then all of a sudden he pulls his
hamstring um you know they're gonna run
the ball um
as just their bread and butter they got
you know three head of monster so um
and they they better do that against uh
carolina tonight because their that
defense is pretty dominant yeah well so
let's get into that steve smith senior
here on the rich eisen show how for real
um how for real are the carolina
panthers steve i think they are for real
um
for what we've seen thus far it's you
know heading into week three um you know
they played the jets in the first time
and i was down and you know down there
in carolina and i'm like hey before you
start buying your super bowl tickets
right let's let's remind ourselves as
the jets
but the way they come in week two
against
um the new orleans saints and
how dominant they were they have been
right the last two years having 18 draft
picks
over the last two years and using 11
defensive players
to acquire through the draft and what is
dominant their defense so
but what's even surprising is sam
darnold
how well he's played uh thus far how
calm he's looked based off the last time
we saw him
playing football in a non-carolina
panther uniform was with the jets and he
didn't look
halfway or even close to what you were
seeing today so
matt rule is doing an exceptional job of
being a head coach there and heading
into his third year and then scott
fitter the general manager
you can just see how
he how his
his finger his pulse is on that drive
because they had so many more draft
picks in the second draft uh under scott
fitter so it's just been a
a unique transition for scott fiddler
and matt rule um and everything that has
been surprising by the carolina panthers
and how they're playing
i think it just kind of goes to the
changing of the guard and the
organization that's uh that seems to be
moving upper uh year by year and by the
looks of it game by game so then how
real is real because you got the
defending super bowl champs in the top
of that division
real enough to even give them uh a fight
what do you think i think i think real
enough to give them a fight you see the
dallas cowboys defensively getting after
tom brady that gives you a chance and
then if your offense
can
somehow
you know go
first down the
first down versus first down with the
tom brady uh
you have a chance at least right you
make it competitive
and so if this defense can stay dominant
and sam darnold can keep
quiet feet
they he has the weapons already they
have a running game with christian being
back he's on pace to possibly have over
500 touches that would be a
nfl record since uh demarco marion
murray did it with i think 492 in 2018.
i'm sorry 2014.
man it'll be it'll be very interesting
steve smith senior here on the rich
eisen show from houston texas where
thursday night football exclusively on
nfl network we'll kick off week number
three carolina versus houston uh what
did you make of the ravens win and how
real they can be um lamar doing
lamar things um but it's still just when
it comes to what deep ball passing game
i
it just sometimes
appears to be a
a struggle
what do you think steve smith well
you know me and and and being a former
wide receiver um i'm actually going to
shock you go for it i was watching that
game and i was thinking the same thing
like man you know the deep ball and this
and that
but then you just got to watch the game
and really just go
man that was great darn football
right it was exciting um yeah
when you compare lamar jackson how he
scored 36 points
uh in the baltimore ravens of and how
kansas city got their points
we can we could break it down and look
at it all we want but the end of the day
it's about to win right and lamar
jackson took over that game and if if
that's the kind of football that he he's
going play week in and week out
you can't really question how he's doing
it you just gotta
you know you just it's like it's like
wearing a hat
going on a boat ride you just gotta hold
on to you hold on to your hat because
it's gonna be windy and it's gonna be a
bumpy ride but in the end
if you got a young man like that when he
decides to take over a game
your defense can't do anything about it
you can blitz them you can do all that
you want
his will was bigger than their will and
and lamar jackson is showing that he's a
guy that can take over a game and yet
not you know not with his arm but just
also with his legs steve smith senior
here on the rich eisen show how
vulnerable are the chiefs then what do
you think
i mean if they got to play lamar jackson
every week
well i mean they still had it the game
pretty much in their hands if if if uh
edward zillaire didn't put the ball on
the ground get it knocked out by bioway
i mean you know i mean you get to pick
you don't get to pick how you win you
just you just got to take advantage of
the opportunities and that's what they
did
i i'm telling you i agree with
everything you're saying but i was
literally sitting on the couch watching
and i'm going
wow
right and instead of just nitpicking it
i just
literally sat there and enjoy it it was
an old football game
that really for me i was sitting there
going this is why our game is so
addictive like this this legal drug on
the on the sports market
man if this is how we're going to be
man give me this give me this kind of
game every week
any team
for the next you know the next 15 weeks
steve smith senior year on the rich
eisen show how did it hit you to see
your name on the list eligible for
enshrinement in the pro football hall of
fame
steve it was it was
it was pretty cool man it really is like
uh
i usually stare
i usually kind of stay away from that
stuff and you know and you know
really for me um by being honest like
it's been a goal of mine since uh i
hired a
sports a sports
psychologist it kind of helped me with
you know figuring out my my goals
almost like a career coach but it was in
sports he used to be he actually is a
golf uh
psychologist
and since february 2002 that was my
lifetime goal to be a hall of famer um
and my my name is on there so um that
means i'm one step closer it may not
happen this year next year whatever it
is but i'm one step closer than the guys
whose name aren't on it so that's all i
could be thankful for and uh and trying
to
try to live in that moment and and have
the right perspective well tonight
you're going to be in the stadium where
you played your super bowl steve smith
and and and what if i had walked up to
you pregame
you know hey steve smith senior you're
going to be in the hall of fame on the
list one day for enshrinement what would
you said it was right after i guess you
had hired that
that uh that coach to help you uh order
your thoughts on that front
right pretty much um
the radio version is man shut the front
door
man but it's uh
here's the coolest part um
you know and i got four kids
and my kids have all known about ball
um but what's been cool you know with me
doing tv and and sometimes their show
highlights my youngest uh junior
and be like daddy why did i have you in
a blue jersey like what is that
[Music]
and every all my kids have been around
football except my youngest he was he
was around it you know his last my last
three years he was literally just born
and for him to go through that and uh
him to go through and go through this
process has been really cool
because he'll see old stuff uh and the
best is when he sees me with hair he's
like daddy who's that
why is he wearing your number and he has
hair so it's been really cool to go down
memory lane with my family um so
whatever happens
you know i've always watched it
and i think about the players
but in this process as i'm going through
it
my kids have been interactive and
allowing them to
experience this more than me i think
that's going to be the funnest part and
that's the perspective that i'm having i
played 16 years and
i was
a lot of people shout out my name um but
when you go through this process i'm
saying i want to make sure this is an
opportunity if if i go through the to
the full process
that my family experience
the kind of uh
and uh
the kind of appreciation
that they have to have had
because they they sacrifice a lot of
times for me to go to work for me to
miss games so this opportunity for them
to be celebrated uh for what they
sometimes were put on the sideline to
observe that's amazing because of my job
that's amazing man and but by the way
look i don't have the receiving yards or
the athletic ability as you steve but we
do share one thing in common though and
that is children looking at old footage
of me saying who's that guy with hair
so um i'm i'm with you i'm also one of
those guys that can say you should be in
the hall of fame you can't
but you deserve it and i'm also one of
the guys who can ask you this question
here's the one
tonight
will you have the list of the pro
football hall of fame eligible players
you on it go up to david cully and point
out you're eligible as a receiver and
not a special teamer
will you do that tonight steve
no
that's a good one here's what i'll tell
you about
i hate to say it but i will admit it yes
sir he's actually fought for what he has
inherited yes which is a uh cluster
he's actually doing a really good job
i've been watching games trying to find
a [ __ ] in his armor
and that's some people have said on
social media steve is so petty and my
response is super but he's doing a hell
of a job and
i don't think
someone else
that was in that position would be able
to do a good job it's as good as the job
he's doing look at dan campbell up at
the lines he's in over his skis but
coach culley has actually been doing a
really good job and so uh if i get the
opportunity yes sir i will walk up to
him and tell him you know great job he's
doing a hell of a job you have a problem
eating humble pie man okay
steve smith high road steve smith is a
great steve smith a great steve smith
but we don't want him back
man i've been i've been sitting in the
house a long time
but that's steve smith that was told in
the pro bowl back in the day go work out
with the
go work out what the special teamers not
the wide receivers by david colley want
you to go up with that list and say how
do you like me now that's steve smith no
i'm paying hey that was uh
that was isaac bruce that was pretty i i
love that that was pretty good that was
great how about that isaac bruce
literally his whole career does not say
two words or pound his chest come even
close hall of fame he starts dropping
mics like how do you like me now that
was amazing that's pretty cool that was
great that was great another reason why
i want to see in the hall i can't wait
for that speech um steve congrats on
being on that list i look forward to
watching you make all those cut downs
from here on out i'll be watching
tonight on nfl network let's do this
again very soon all right appreciate it
right back at you that's steve smith
steve smith senior on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line right here on the rich
eisen show hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here